a new thin film of quantum dots covers
glass and transforms windows into solar
panels the dots have a lifespan of 14
years and right now they're trying to
raise their energy conversion efficiency
from 1.9 percent to a more practical six
percent and can Goro's a bio humanoid
robot from the University of Tokyo that
cools itself by sweating Vsauce Kevin
here this is Milo kernel is developing a
memory prosthesis the new company has
invested 100 million dollars to further
over two decades of neuro prosthetic
research by biomedical engineer Theodore
burger while company founder Brian
Johnson has long-term science-fiction
goals like the ability to download
knowledge or exchange memories the
current plan is to help people suffering
from memory disorders for instance using
an algorithm to instruct electrodes
involved in long-term memory to restore
the circuitry in people suffering from
Alzheimer's boosting brains to learn a
thousand times faster what happens
sometime down the road a new hybrid
power fabric uses solar as well as
mechanical movement to harness power
solar cells are made into micro cable
structures and woven with nano
generators to create the smart fabric
not only does it charge using ambient
light but the mechanical movement allows
wind and human motion to gather energy
and researchers from the Georgia
Institute of Technology say the fabric
could be used in tents wearable garments
like scarves or curtains navdy is like
projecting your smartphone onto your
windshield
the head-up display is the world's first
augmented driving device that allows GPS
navigation and phone access without
taking your eyes off the road the
steering wheel dial allows for scrolling
through or skipping songs and zooming in
and out of the map while gesture
controls handle accepting and dismissing
phone calls and after beginning
pre-orders two years ago they just
started shipping this week a
brain implant allows you to feel with
the robotic hand neural engineers at the
University of Pittsburgh used magnetic
resonance imaging to map the regions of
the patient's brain associated with
imagining and touch on different parts
of the hand after getting used to the
system the patient could recognize the
location of the touches on the robotic
hand with 100% accuracy but it's still
very early on it's proof of principle
stage Sundrop is the world's first farm
growing vegetables in the desert using
seawater 15 thousand tons of tomatoes a
year are now being grown in Australia
using 23,000 mirrors that generate solar
power and seawater from the Spencer Gulf
the solar power is used to desalinate or
remove the salt from the sea water to
create fresh water for the crops and
they're now planning to create these
farms in Portugal and the United States
these e-paper displays are like reusable
digital post-it notes Microsoft Research
developed the display to run on office
lights using a solar panel on the back
it can communicate with other eat paper
displays via Bluetooth that can be
updated with an app and have a sticky
back to attach to stuff easily right now
this is just a prototype and isn't
commercially available yet drones can be
charged in midair using technology from
Nikola Tesla scientists from Imperial
College London used inductive coupling
demonstrated by Tesla which allows for
wireless exchange of power between
copper coils they're about a year away
from making this commercially available
and say that this technology could also
be used in healthcare devices as well as
interplanetary missions finally Stanford
engineers have developed gecko inspired
grippers to grab and move space debris
I've learned from gecko lizards to make
small adhesive grippers that here to
smooth surfaces such as solar panels and
fuel tanks with really little attachment
and detachment effort
similar functions have been achieved
with the curved gripper ladle attachment
force strong grip and cleaned attachment
I'm gonna leave you with a body movement
activated midair display and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
there are those who say today that
opportunities have ceased to exist
things are finished we have everything
and not enough for years the oil men
cursed gasoline it was a troublesome
by-product and they dumped millions of
gallons of it into the rivers and
streams then science discovered that
gasoline was liquid horsepower in any
one of thousands of test tubes of today
there may be a million job opportunities
for tomorrow and the industrial
scientists and engineers are the
pioneers of present-day America the
creators of progress of new industries
and new jobs
it's a bewildering future all right not
because there are no new frontiers but
progress
[Music]
hey I have a couple of really cool
announcements first of all and made a
series with Google arts and culture
called hyper history it's a super quick
look at really fascinating things
throughout history including topics from
duck-billed platypuses - the missing
link so click here or click the link at
the top of this video's description to
watch all five episodes that's five more
episodes of me talking about stuff that
you should really check out also
curiosity box number one is almost gone
forever hang on who oh it's heavy
because it's full of awesome great stuff
but like I said there's only a couple of
days left to go until this baby has gone
forever you can no longer get all of the
exclusive items available like this
great vsauce t-shirt of a deep-sea diver
climbing a tree pointing at the vsauce
constellation this actually glows in the
dark it's ridiculously cool so if you
want to get in on the ground floor of
the Curiosity Box you have to order
right now okay like right now like
curiosity voxcom have to go there in
order right now after I say the word now
[Music]
now